nella mia vita di comico mi sono sempre
occupato di satira alla vecchia maniera
cioè non sapete profili digitali sui
social per parlare delle notizie del
giorno dei politici ma cose più vecchie
più all'antica tipo spettacoli teatrali
libri fumetti che sono contenuti che ti
permettono di fare le battute ma anche
di approfondire le questioni di
coltivare il dubbio di mettere in
discussione le certezze mie e delle
persone che ascoltano e di rispondere
alle grandi domande e c'è un tipo di
domanda in particolare che a me ha
sempre interessato tantissimo per
seguire e cioè chiedersi siamo sicuri
che tutto ciò che noi crediamo giusto
nella nostra vita nella nostra società
non possa essere in realtà sbagliato
siamo sicuri che tutte le cose che noi
pensiamo siano buone
auspicabili belle della nostra vita non
possano essere invece nocive dannose
problematiche siamo sicuri che tutti i
valori a cui noi affidiamo le nostre
certezze e quindi anche le nostre scelte
di vita non possano essere invece causa
della nostra infelicità
ecco mi piacerebbe dirvi che io sono
arrivato al femminismo grazie a queste
domande così profonde queste
elucubrazioni molto sagge ma sarò
sincero con voi ci sono arrivato grazie
a kinder
dovete sapere che io qualche anno fa
sono tornato single
venivo da due relazioni molto lunghi e
praticamente durante la mia vita sono
stato sempre fidanzato avuto due
relazioni molto lunghe di cui sono
ancora molto contento da due persone a
cui voglio ancora bene però di fatto da
circa vent'anni fino circa 35 ero sempre
stato in coppia tornato single a 35 anni
ho deciso di prendermi un piccolo
periodo di solitudine volontaria per
capire se potevo cavarmela visto che non
avevo praticamente mai fatto e secondo
voi a 35 anni in questa mia nuova vita
da single
quale era il mio chiodo fisso nella
testa a tutti i giorni
come procurarsi il sesso
nella mia vita e non penso il sesso
penso altre cose ma ho promesso che
stasera non dico cose volgari concedete
ora di problema è che avevo bisogno
veramente a parte tutto perché venivo da
una relazione molto lunga e se c'è una
caratteristica tipica di una relazione
che sta per finire che nell'ultimo
periodo il sesso è praticamente
inesistente quindi sì ero single da due
settimane ma era un astinenza da molto
di più 15 aveva un bisogno urgente solo
che ormai era tantissimo tempo che
proprio mi ero disabituato a fare quel
tipo di vita relazionale non ero più
abituato non sapevo più come si fa
i miei amici ormai erano tutti
accoppiati con famiglia figli e non
potevano dargli una mano io ero
completamente fuori dai giochi non
sapevo come ributtarmi nella piazza
avevo delle persone che conoscevo che
avevano usato team per me ne avevano
parlato io sono sempre stato a favore
delle app di dating perché sono secondo
me tra i pochissimi strumenti che
prendono le persone nel mondo virtuale e
cercherò di riportarle nella vita reale
e quindi ho detto va bene da in stallo
tindari e il posto alla bio due foto e
sono pronto per ricominciare a fare vita
sociale a conoscere nuove persone
questo tanto vituperato sesso
occasionale che ci ricarica la tele
galina e ci fa aumentare i punti
autostima ora ho iniziato a fare i primi
incontri grazie a tingere e al di là di
come andavano che non so che qualcuno
sono state chiedendo che non vi darò
dettagli comunque bene
la cosa che mi colpiva era che
praticamente ogni volta che uscivo una
ragazza chiunque essa fosse che la fosse
chiunque di cosa qualsiasi cosa stavamo
parlando a un certo punto durante la
nostra serata usciva fuori una frase del
tipo io mi sento femminista io sono
femminista e io all'epoca di femminismo
non sapevo niente se non le cose
generiche la parità dei diritti
il fatto che le donne d'italia se non
fanno figli non vengono considerate
oppure quelle altre cose che si dicono
tra maschi tipo a oggi si esce a cena
con una donna gli paghi la cena 6
maschilista a sé gli apre la portiera
una macchina 6 sessista mia signora mia
è tutto un magna magna sopra tutte
quelle cose che non è che io credevo
però erano veramente le uniche
informazioni che avevo mentre invece
parlando tantissimo con le ragazze che
incontravo capivo che era un tema che
ricorreva spesso e quindi ha da qualche
cosa che nella cultura in quel momento
stava entrando in maniera dirompente era
importante per le persone e mi
piacerebbe dirvi che è per questo che ho
deciso di approcciarli al femminismo
perché avevo capito che era una cosa
importante ma voglio essere sincero di
nuovo con voi il mio vero pensiero è
stato caspita se ogni volta che esco che
una ragazza che la parte del femminismo
io mi informo sul femminismo quando ne
parliamo lei vede che ne so qualcosa
pensa che sia una persona sensibile ci
abbiamo un affinità molta più
probabilità di fare sesso lo so magari
che state giudicando e avere anche
ragione però io so quel tipo di maschio
lascia il l'impulso sessuale il motore
della mia iniziativa però grazie a
questa iniziativa io per settimane e
settimane e settimane ho cominciato a
comprare libri da leggere a guardare dei
that talk sul tema a seguire delle
attiviste su internet partecipare a
convegni presentazioni di libri
iniziative organizzate dai movimenti e
cose del genere
per un sacco di tempo mi sono immerso in
questa cultura tutto quello che impara
volo assorbivo e poi ho riportato
parlando con gli amici con le amiche con
le nuove ragazze che incontrava sul team
e via dicendo
e devo dire che fino a quel momento è
stato anche tutto molto facile perché
voluto essere molto istruttivo che ho
imparato un sacco di persone
il vento sacco di questo è un sacco di
cose scusate era molto facile perché
tutto quello che imparava era come se
non mi riguardasse direttamente cioè
tutto quello che io imparavo per esempio
rispetto alla disparità salariale sul
lavoro l'esclusione dalle cariche
dirigenziali delle donne in certi posti
o anche le cose più gravi la violenza le
molestie tutto quello che imparato era
come se non mi riguardasse direttamente
già mi sentivo coinvolto sì ma come
cittadino come persona che fa parte di
questa società è che c'è una sua
piccolissima dose di responsabilità
quando votava cari e quindi ok allora la
prossima volta che devo votare qualcuno
ascolterò quello che c'è da dire sulle
questioni femminili oltre che sugli
immigrati sull'economia e sulla
possibilità che si realizzi il miracolo
della mia pensione va bene però a parte
questo non mi coinvolgeva e non mi
coinvolgeva non è meno i discorsi
generici sul maschilismo volume di diano
perché lo so come sei maschilisti
maschilisti sono quelle persone
sgradevoli che si divertono a mettere in
imbarazzo le donne facendo i commentarci
le battutine i fischi per strada e
quelle cose non le ho mai fatte
ma non perché io sia migliore perché da
ragazzino ero timido ai limiti del
patologico questo faceva sì che le
ragazze che conoscevo pensavano che io
fossi un ragazzo più gentile più carino
diverso dai soliti maschiacci questa
cosa mi piaceva e ho continuato così poi
quando loro si giravano dall'altra parte
io pensavo delle loro tette per loro
culo le stesse identiche cose che
pensavano i maschilisti sono però le
dicevo a voce alta vedremo per me al
massimo le raccontavo a qualche mio
amico in privato così per ridere perché
poi noi siamo fatti così ci piacciono i
corpi femminili siamo tutti e cita terni
quando siamo eccitati dobbiamo fare le
cose anzi che non facevo niente di male
nei confronti di nessuna donna non ero
molesto non disturbava non metteva a
disagio come dovrebbero da una medaglia
no
però questo è quello che io mi ripetevo
e pensavo di essere una brava persona
mentre lo pensavo solo che non me ne
accorgevo era un auto giustificazione ma
non lo faceva apposta a pensare queste
cose e non me ne sono mai accorto fin
che una volta
durante un pomeriggio in cui io stavo
sul divano a leggere l'ennesimo libro
sul femminismo in attesa di uscire la
sera con una ragazza conosciuta su
tender in quel momento vengo fulminato
da un ricordo
prima di mi ricordo vi devo fare una
premessa io non ho sempre voluto fare
l'attore nella vita
io da piccolo era un piccolo on earth ho
iniziato a programmare computer all'età
di otto anni quello che ho fatto per
tutta la mia vita fino a vent'anni è
stato giocare ai videogiochi programmare
computer e sognare di lavora
nell'informatica ho frequentato il
tecnico industriale ho lavorato in
azienda poi per motivi che non sto a
raccontare ho cambiato totalmente scelte
di vita mi sono messo a fare teatro è a
22 anni mi sono ritrovato a fare il mio
primo spettacolo teatrale con i miei
compagni di accademia
fatta questa premessa in ricordo volevo
parlare ed era questo
io praticamente il primo giorno di studi
desco dal primo giorno dello spettacolo
e
i panni dell'accademia eravamo nel
camerino ci dovevamo vestire e truccare
e io per la prima volta stava mettendo
che la matita sotto gli occhi era la
prima volta che faceva un gesto sul mio
corpo del genere
m me mi ricordo che in quel momento ha
22 anni è la prima volta in vita mia che
mi metto la matita sugli occhi io
davanti allo specchio ho avuto paura
la prima immagine che il mio cervello ha
partorito sono stati i miei compagni
delle superiori che mi prendevano in
giro e mi facevano le battutacce sulla
mia ormai evidente passione per il bene
la seconda immagine che ho partorito è
stata la smorfia di disgusto di mio
padre che mi guardava con sospetto per
quella sua un po bigotta visione della
promiscuità sessuale del mondo dello
spettacolo la terza immagine era
semplicemente gente sconosciuta che mi
puntava il dito e divideva in faccia e
io davanti a quelle immagini davanti a
quelle voci ho iniziato nella mia testa
giustificarmi no ma io sta cosa l'avevo
fa perché lo spettacolo bisogna farla
così ma nun me piace a truccarmi a me
che c'entra e lo devo fà prezzi equi
lavoro cioè mi fa schifo non lo farei
poi non c'è niente di male se uno lo
vuole fare alle persone sono libere gli
altri però io non c'entro non è la cosa
che mi riguarda non lo fanno belle ma a
me piacciono le femmine ste cose
insomma ho iniziato a verona piccoli una
piccola reazione di panico perché
sentivo il giudizio di queste persone
che ne è che c'erano però evidentemente
c'era nella mia testa e su di me
esercitavano una pressione insistente e
un po ansiogeno ecco io ero sul divano a
leggere questo libro questo ricordo mi
torna in mente all'improvviso una cosa a
cui non avevo
avevo mai raccontato a nessuno e in quel
momento per la prima volta da quando la
sento nominare
capisco riconosco che cos'è la
mascolinità tossica le voci quelle poi
ci sono le voci che io ho sempre sentito
fin da quando ero bambino che mi sono
arrivata in maniera disordinata dai
maschi più grandi dai miei compagni più
spavaldi che l'avevano imparate dai
maschi più grandi a volte anche dalle
donne ed erano quelle voci che mi hanno
spiegato come deve essere il maschio
erano quelle voci che mi hanno spiegato
che un maschio si comporta con le donne
in determinati modi
c'è un codice comportamentale per ogni
tipo di donna c'è un codice per la mamma
un codice per le sorelle un codice per
le cugine tipo le sorelle ma un po più
libertino un codice per le compagne di
classe e poi per le colleghi di lavoro
per la fidanzata per le fidanzate degli
amici non sono ti insegna questo codice
ma queste voci tiri e pronti
rimproverano ti puniscono e che umiliano
se non seguì questo codice e ti dicono
che sei un debole un vigliacco fallito o
la colpa più grave di tutte per un
maschio etero uno sterminato e io in
quel momento mi sono reso conto che
quelle voci che erano sempre state nella
mia testa è neanche vennero mai accorto
erano le voci che avevano sorvegliato
costantemente il mio rapporto con le
donne per tutta la mia vita ho ammesso a
me stesso che ogni volta che io facevo
dicevo qualche cosa in presenza di una
ragazza non lo facevo pensando alla
ragazza ma pensavo alle voci pensavo se
è quello che stavo dicendo e facendo
sarebbe piaciuto alle voci se loro mi
avrebbero approvato poi se quello che io
dicevo e facevo dava fastidio alla
ragazza adatti a me è quella e perché le
donne sono così so così sono complicate
sono permaloso e non si capisce mai
niente tanto io sono un maschio inutile
pure che invece cervello legami non mai
queste voci qui erano quelle che avevano
veramente guidato tutto il mio
comportamento
quindi improvvisamente io mi sono reso
conto che nonostante la vita che dico
che a me piacciono le femmine
ogni volta che mi sono rapportato alle
femmine non volevo piacere alle femmine
volevo piacere ai maschi
improvvisamente mi è crollato tutto il
mondo addosso
ho cominciato a pensare ma possibile che
tutto quello che io ho sempre ritenuto
normale giusto nelle relazioni tra
maschi e femmine
in realtà è una cretinata assurda
possibile io pensavo semplicemente di
essere un maschio etero normale giusto e
invece siccome ho potuto fare questo
esperimento conti l'inter mi sono
immerso per mesi e mesi in una cultura
che mi circondava di altre voci
alternative che mi dicevano che non è
vero niente e non è vero niente perché
tutte le difficoltà che io sento quando
sono da solo è però ad ascoltarmi
vengono dal fatto che fino adesso sono
cresciuto senza mai ascoltare i miei
veri sentimenti perché dovevo ascoltare
i sentimenti che il maschio deve provare
queste voci mi dicevano che io ho
eliminato totalmente dall'equazione
delle relazioni umane l'elemento
fondamentale che è l'empatia ma di fatti
ma chi caspita lei empatizza toe con le
femmine
io il pareggio con gli amici e gli amici
non li possono trattare come tratto le
femmine con le femmine ci voglio fare
sesso e come dice una famosa canzone
degli anni 90 se sei amico di una donna
non ci combinerai mai niente
ma quella canzone non è che ha creato il
mostro l'ha fotografato
è stato veramente difficile
decostruire tutto e ricominciare da capo
e stato difficile perché la cosa più
difficile è ammettere che devi farlo una
volta che tu ammetti che devi farlo gli
strumenti per farlo sono semplici
parlare ascoltare e ascoltarsi
questo è più facile io dopo aver
chiarito certe cose mi sono impegnato
nel parlare tantissimo con le persone a
me vicine non tantissimo con i miei
amici maschi lo ammetto un po di più con
le mie amiche femmine in particolare con
tre di loro che per un periodo penso che
non volendo mi abbiano fatte dal fatto
da sorelle maggiori
chissà che timidezza che devo aver di
fatto mentre mi vedevano crescere
a più di trent'anni
carroccio
però vabbè meglio tardi che mai comunque
adesso io sono un momento sono un
momento cresciuto un momento sicuro di
essere eterosessuale anche se mi
commuovo con i film romantici mi piace
praticare comuni lingus però mi piace
anche tantissimo arrivarmi le unghie con
l'albergo all'anima è vero mi piace
guardare il calcio ma non mi piace
parlarne mi piacciono gli abbracci non
mi vergogno se mi viene da piangere in
pubblico però un po mi vergogno se non
riesco aprì un barattolo insomma sono
fatto così ed ho un rapporto molto
migliore con me stesso ed ho un rapporto
migliore anche col femminismo non è che
siamo d'accordo sempre su tutto tutto è
però di base quando dice qualcosa mi
fido di più perché se aveva così tanto
ragione su di me è molto probabile che
abbia ragione anche sulle questioni che
riguardano la parità i diritti la
società la famiglia alle relazioni
l'economia e la politica cose di cui non
vi parlerò in chiave femminista primo
perché ci sono persone molto più
preparate di me e secondo perché cioè il
terrore di fare il mens plaining senza
accorgermene mi fermo qua
ora io so che io ho finito questo
discorso e probabilmente in molte
persone che stanno ascoltando sia qui
che anche in video potrebbe essere
rimasta sospesa una domanda fin
dall'inizio che è ok ma quindi sto
femminismo su twitter fa
viaggiare parecchio
però detto aggiunto direi mai ingannare
ma non posso dire modalità eco se c'è
una cosa che ho imparato dal femminismo
e che mi ha in aree parecchio come
obiettivo di appagamento felicità
soddisfazione è un obiettivo proprio
sbagliato perché l'essere umano per come
è fatto non è contento e felice quando
il senso lo fa tanto ma quando lo fa
bene
cosa che noi maschietti soprattutto
tendiamo a voler trascurare a non
imparare ed è un peccato perché va da sé
che quando una cosa la fai bene poi la
fai anche tanto e quando la fai male che
alla gente che passa la voglia
e sembra una cosa scema ma la
soddisfazione sessuale nella vita è una
delle basi fondamentali per essere
felici sia che una accoppiata si sa se
uno è single
a proposito è tutto questo io frattempo
mi sono ri fidanzato ea parte con le con
la mia autore compagna si segna molto
bene ok ma
da quello che volevo dire che a 40 anni
ho imparato a stabilire un rapporto con
lei di condivisioni aperture in timida
che io non ho mai avuto commesso un
altro la mia vita fin da subito e questo
sia perché lei è molto brava ma anche
perché grazie al femminismo imparato
come si fa con me e con gli altri quello
che ho imparato veramente dal femminismo
è che il maschio non esiste il maschio è
un armatura che c'è stata messa addosso
e che noi invece di voler difendere a
tutti i costi per paura di rimanere
scoperti ed essere giudicati da quelle
voci
dobbiamo avere il coraggio di toglier
cielo e scoprire che sotto al maschio ci
sono io
cioè l'essere umano